hello the names right Rowan right this
is my awesome British accent this is a
classy spy Bell even sounds British
Spectre spectra no [ __ ] no Abraham to
finally trailers outs next Bond film
direct sequel to Skyfall director Sam
Mendes is back I finally have the
trailer loaded on my computer let's
watch this actually just realise how
excited for this I am forensics finally
released this what is it
person effects they recovered from
Skyfall you've got a secret
something you can't tell anyone because
you don't trust anyone
there was new death we're familiar face
looking for humans I was at a meeting
recently
Betty Logan still wasn't mi6
you're the kite dancing American Mr Bond
welcome Jake's this fellow won't fight
interesting so does James Bond have a
brother that we don't know about
I guess it's bond is related to someone
who's part of spectra the secret
organization it looks like a secret
organization to me it doesn't it's
pretty clear it's a secret organization
just somewhat this trailer is offering
us alone
the tone of it just seems a lot darker
like whoa I was watching this going I
know sequels tend to go darker but this
feels like really dark it feels like it
might be like an emotional James Bond
film Sam Mendes did a great job at
Skyfall but he's done a lot of movies
that are very emotional you know
American Beauty Revolutionary Road Road
to Perdition so I wonder if he's gonna
add more of that flare into these films
something that has a lot more emotion
does this trailer is really promoting
the the mystery of it all and his dark
hidden past coming to light but he
doesn't promote the action-adventure
whatsoever it's just mainly about the
mystery and hinting at bond secret past
which I wonder how much more we can
really get of this because just to
reveal a little bit more of his past in
Skyfall kind of takes away some of the
image of bond because part of what keeps
bond Grady's that we don't know his past
and it sounds like we're gonna even
learn more about it so this could be a
great film but there's only so much we
can keep learning about bonds past and
everything that I wonder will this
affect the bond films in the long run
will this cause it to conclude because
they can't just suddenly hop back to oh
we're just you know doing another
mission and there's a hot girl
Skyfall worked out so great if this
works out great we're gonna want more of
that but will that actually affect our
perception of bond in the long run you
know now that we get to really know him
will it take away so much of his mystery
anyway I'm gonna see it regardless I
mean it's [ __ ] the Sam Mendes he's
one of my favorite directors so if you
guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the reel rejects and you
can follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
that's right social networks people
because I'm ready to connect with you
on a more personal level I am a youtuber
so I am designed to say things like that
Kyle MacLeod me me Clooney Ryan came
across your channel a while ago you
always make me laugh
lots of love all the way from shitty
Scotland it's in the UK by the way
thanks for that geography information
well Kyle Michael Oh Nick who's just
shocked out what a man looking at your
profile pictures you you are exactly
what I'd expect a Scottish person to be
like you it's from Scotland you just
party it up like all the time here's you
with a picture of you [ __ ] on the
toilet here's you [ __ ] drunk as [ __ ]
at a party and here's you having beer
with a friend at like 8:00 a.m. I'm not
racist
but if there is anything I can gather
from your photos is that you are the
exact stereotypical cliche of what a
Scottish person is supposed to be like
that's what three photos have told me